[Music]
let's go to tyler in dallas what's up
tyler
hi can you hear me i can what's up
okay
um uh
so i don't i don't know where to start
um just anywhere is cool we can make it
up as we go
okay okay
um i have come i guess to the conclusion
um that my parents
were very
emotional and mature i think is the word
and um
it was really hard
and uh like growing up and
i had a older brother who
like really scared me a lot
and um
and i just didn't
know what to do
and um
uh
i
as a 15 year old you know what else do
you do
um i say that kind of like as a joke
how did your brother scare you
um just like
really aggressively it wasn't anything
like like sexual or anything but just
i mean he would like come at me like
across the room and like get in my face
and um did he ever hit you
uh not so much like by the time i was 15
but when we were younger um he would
like literally push us down and like get
in our face and like pin us down
and like wouldn't let us go
and
and um
you said us did you have other siblings
in the house yeah i had i have two older
brothers and a younger sister and um
i like i would i would like to lay awake
and like
be scared
and i don't know sometimes i just wish
my sister was a little bit more vocal
than i was and
i was scared for her and i would just
think like just hush like you don't know
what he's going to do yeah and um
anyway i'm sorry
no don't hold on never apologize okay
i'm so sorry that happened
your older brother is supposed to be
your pathway through life right
supposed to clear the deck for his baby
sister
supposed to
supposed to hold her up hold on hold on
hold on
your brother should have given you some
things that he didn't give you and i'm
so sorry
and your parents should not have let
that nonsense go on and i'm so sorry
um thank you and um
i don't i've never actually said like
things like that out loud um
anyway so
i'm just by myself a lot because i just
don't want to be around people and
you know your mind
can
take advantage of you sometimes and
i uh i
started like self-harming i guess yeah
maybe is the term to use i don't know
that's all that's all that's like all
clinically uh
tell me about what actually happens in
practice
um
i guess maybe like cutting myself yeah
um
and
anyway it was never for like
like suicidal reasons it was just
i don't know how i got to that point i
don't know how i
i don't know
what made me think that was
a good thing to do i don't know
um
anyway so
that's kind of the premise of
my recent
problems um
i had my and i did that all through high
school and then after high school it got
a lot better um my brother did
eventually
um move out and eventually stopped
coming back
and
so that helped a lot and i met my
husband and that helped a lot a lot
and
um
so i thought it was getting better i
thought i was
getting better
and um
anyway
two years ago i had
my second son
and
around three to four months i noticed
there was just something different
and
i couldn't handle it i just couldn't
handle it and
um
i
i just sort of like started
i guess cutting myself again and i
i didn't know what to do and
over time i think i've i've gotten a
little better
and
but now i worry that like what if it
comes back
and
you know i have kids now and
i just i don't know what to do and i
want to
talk to someone that
i don't know like necessarily what to
say and
yeah
i don't know i i'm worried that
like
i'm worried that
if i start talking to
like let's say a professional
does that mean i have to kind of like
tell everyone
else and because i don't i don't want to
tell everyone else i don't know if
that's
like the wrong way to look at it but i
don't want anyone to know and
my husband does
know as far as
before we met and
but he i don't i don't think he knows
like recently
and
unless he just doesn't want to say i
don't know um
and i i don't want to i don't want him
to start worrying about me
i don't know i don't know what to do so
number one tyler i wanna
this is
some of the bravest five minutes that
has ever taken place on this show
okay
okay
in your heart
silence keeps you safe
disappearing keeps you safe
and it has your whole life
and at the same time our bodies will
scream at us from the inside out
help help help help help right
and you've learned you watched your
sister who talked a lot she got it worse
than you did
and you learned silence
and that thing that kept you alive
is now slowly burying you right
and so
before we start walking into some of
this i need you to hear me say loudly
when you tell me that you're cutting
that doesn't even make my eyes browse go
up
you're not broken you're not screwed up
you're not messed up
you're not dysfunctional you're not less
than okay
and if you've listened to this show
people tell me things and i go whoa oh
my goodness it i'm not doing that with
this
okay
okay
um
i can tell that this is a coping
strategy you don't want to use anymore
and i applaud that and i think there's
some way better coping strategies but
given what you've experienced and i bet
you and i could sit down for a couple
hours over some nachos and you could
tell me some stories that would make my
eyebrows go through the top of my
forehead is that probably true
is that is that honestly true
um yeah
just things like that my parents used to
say that's right and that your brother
sometimes yeah there you go
and so
the first thing you do me a huge favor i
want you to take as deep a breath as you
possibly can hold it all the way in and
breathe it all the way in and hold it
ready go
hold it
and let it out
and right now i bet your shoulders are
two inches from your ears i want you
just to drop them down
okay
saying
you're hurt out loud is one of the
single bravest things you can do
and you just did it
and i'm so proud of you i'm glad to call
you my friend okay
okay
um
so
cutting is i'll do a whole show on it
one day we'll do a whole segment on it
one day okay that's not for today but
we'll do that one day i'll kind of walk
through it all
ultimately over the last 20 years i've
worked with so many young people usually
women um young women who are deal who
are dealing with stressors that that
exceed their body's ability to help
themselves
okay
it's when like this cup only holds this
much water and the pipe bursts above it
and i uh i've been really inspired by dr
anna lemke's work about dopamine and how
the pain pleasure balance works and all
that but
most of the time over the last 20 years
the words i've heard repeatedly are
something along the lines of
i just had to feel something
i needed a release
it doesn't even hurt it just makes
everything feel a little bit better
did any one of those three words apply
to your your situation
yeah i would definitely say it was just
it was
i don't know it seems simple
don't minimize it it what's one of the
ones that made the most sense to you
just then
um
maybe just head
maybe the last one
you may have to repeat it
just just that um everything builds up
inside so much and it doesn't even hurt
as much as
i can see it
i can see the
the bits of blood i can see it i can
feel it and then shortly thereafter
yes definitely like how your voice is
right now after taking one deep breath
and dropping your shoulders
it's it's that right
um our bodies release our own opioids
when we're hurt
and sometimes there's there's a hack
to it's it's not an all the way opi it's
not like taking you know oxies or
something but there is a path that way
that sometimes just goes
okay
i want you to know as a little girl
who had a
repeated
trauma with her big brother you had a
bear that your body was trying to run
from except he lived in the next room
over
right
that you have a little cup underneath
the pipe that had burst and it just
overflowed and so as a high school kid
i'm so sorry that you had to deal with
that by yourself
you're not screwed up from cutting
where you end up getting yourself well
i've seen people get themselves into
trouble let me say it that way with
cutting is the shame that follows
and it's everything is about secrecy
everything is about i just have this
i've got this tool i've got this hack
that lets me get to the next minute into
the next minute into the next minute
and as i've heard you say it i don't
want anyone to if i tell a therapist i
have to tell everybody i didn't want my
husband to know that's the language of
shame
that's the language of somewhere deep
inside is a little girl asking herself
why wouldn't my parents just freaking
protect me
and they didn't
why didn't my older brother be the
normal older brother
and beat up my boyfriends and make jokes
but also i knew i was a princess around
him
why didn't i get that older brother
right
does that sound right
yes i used to look at my friends and
like had like when their siblings and i
don't know how they had that
so
here is the
here is the
i want to take cutting and put over to
the side for a second because as far as
i'm concerned right now cutting is not
the problem cutting's the solution okay
so when you feel that urge
and also it's super common with um
post-pregnancy okay
postpartum cutting is super common too
there's that sense of like i don't know
what are we what are we doing what are
we doing and it just builds and builds
and builds and builds right going back
to i've got that little cup and it's
overflowing so let's put cutting over to
the side here okay that's not the
problem
the problem
again this is you and i talking for just
a few minutes here but the big neon sign
that i want to start with
is
what kept you alive is now hurting you
okay the same thing that kept you alive
is not hurting you and that's silence
the greatest gift you can give your body
your husband your children
you
is to begin to tell your story
it's to
uh as the great brene brown says shame
eats secrets for breakfast and so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start to lean into and a secret free
life
and here's what that will do it will be
the most exposing it will be like
running down the street naked in a
parade
okay
you've never done it you've never had to
do it and it's gonna be a skill that
you're going to have to learn and
practice
and it's going to come in fits and
starts and rages and tears and yelling
and hiding it's going to come all that
stuff to expect it
the same as you went and had surgery and
you have to go through rehab that's
where we're at now we're going to learn
how to tell
what happened
and we're going to do that with a
therapist who knows what they're talking
about and when you go see a counselor
you have to tell
nobody
and if the counselor tells somebody
they're breaking the law okay
and their license gets taken away
but this story's got to be told just
feel how your body feels right now after
saying it once for the first time
yeah and when you find yourself in a
position where you feel like cutting
you're going to develop and it's not
going to take you super long
you're going to develop a language with
your husband where you say hey i'm
feeling really stressed right now
and that's not you being a wimp that's
not you
uh running and hiding that's you
understanding that your voice matters
that your your role and your
relationship matters that you matter
and that right now i'm starting to
things are piling up on me
sure we all know that seven miles down
the road what that could end up at that
could end up as me cutting again that
could end up as me having too many
drinks or in my house that could end up
with me and four cartons of ice cream in
the middle of the front yard and i'm not
wearing a shirt i'm just sitting in a
bathing suit like a weirdo right it can
we all know where that could go those
are all solutions the problems are back
here
does that sound
reasonable
yeah
i'm nervous you're going to get off the
phone you're going to feel better for
about five minutes and you're not going
to say anything
i don't know what to say
would you call a counselor today in your
area and tell them i'm not okay
yeah i can
do you promise that you'll do that
i i promise
if you my dad um he was a homicide
detective for a long time but then he
became a minister for a short season for
a while for several years and so since
my dad's a minister if you lie to me
it's all you'll get struck by lightning
or something like that
[Music]
it's not really true i just made that up
do you promise she'll make that call
i will i will here's the second here's
the second conversation
i want you to bring your husband on
board
okay will you tell him that you're not
okay
uh i will
i may let him listen to this call maybe
it won't come out for like a month
oh yeah yeah you're right here
[Laughter]
nice try tyler
i know buy into okay how about this okay
well they're gonna clip it and they're
gonna send it to you is that cool
okay yeah that's great here's what i
heard when you just mentioned your
husband he's an incredible guy isn't he
he is
like of all of the men who failed you
before your brothers your dad
he stepped up huh
okay
it's gonna be hard to reach out across
that and trust and i think he's earned
that according to you right he's earned
that trust and yeah
so i want you to do it while holding his
hands okay
okay so here's how the conversation goes
i talked to this podcaster today and
your husband's going to go what i
thought you were and he's like i know i
know i know i made a call and then we
held him and then you want you to hold
his hands and say i've got some hard
things i got to tell you
starting with i'm not okay
starting with um
the stress is built up and i've got some
stuff that i've got to deal with from
all the way back to when i was a little
girl but it's paying off right now i've
started cutting again
i'm stressed and i'm struggling um and
i'm gonna reach out to a counselor and i
want you to walk alongside me in this
i want you just to say it just like that
okay okay and he sounds like a man who
will
grab you in his arms and hold you tight
and say i love you
i'm not gonna try to solve you i'm not
gonna try to give you advice i love you
and then we're gonna start from there is
that cool
yeah is that the kind of guy he is
yeah he's the best
it's so good
so good can i tell you
i don't come face to face
nose to nose eye to eye with bravery
very often and i did today
and you and i could i could say we could
spin this is just scratching the surface
of this call and i know that sweetie and
i know that you and i could talk for a
long time about cutting and about trauma
and about your brother's abuse and about
your parents dysfunction i know all that
stuff but right now
everything is you looking in the mirror
and saying
i got two little babies i got a great
husband and most importantly i got me
and i'm worth
this conversation i'm worth calling and
getting help i'm worth not carrying the
stuff around am i carrying my parents
crap anymore i'm not curing my brother's
crap anymore
i'm changing this family tree and it
starts today
so so grateful for you tyler bravery